every corner of america is reeling from
an unmistakable act of political
violence
an eruption after the slow creep of a
new
kind of radicalism a mainstream movement
we will stop the steal
[Applause]
we're gonna walk down to the capitol
because you'll never take back our
country with weakness
you have to show strength and you have
to be strong
the siege on the capital isn't a simple
story of emboldened
far-right groups or extremists lots of
individuals unconnected to any
organization or
ideology were there too just enraged
by the idea of a stolen election and
freedom sucking pandemic
that mix of frustration fear anxiety
and the political and social issues of
2020 created
this breeding ground for extremism
those facing charges come from all over
some from here in colorado
many middle class and middle aged as a
range of rioters are investigated
political rhetoric is also under the
microscope
ties to extremist groups are under
scrutiny with
rising concern about a caucus of
conspiracy theorists
connected to militia groups and one new
member of congress from here in colorado
has sparked a lot of controversy
lauren bobert is one of many pro-gun
americans but
some critics want her expelled
i will carry my firearm in dc and in
congress
this caused outrage from democrats in
the media why
it's our job in congress to defend your
rights
last year she declared i am the militia
once posing for a photo with several
people appearing to flash a hand gesture
of the three percenters group bobert is
not an extremist but
she is a defiant newcomer with many
heavily armed fans she's not the only
new recruit
republicans are wrestling with i'm
marjorie green
and i approve this ad enter a
congresswoman who's been willing to
embrace conspiracy theories
and who once confronted the school
shooting survivor
he's a coward he can't say one word
because he can't defend his stance
because there is no defense for taking
away guns
there is no defense for gun confiscation
i'm running to stop gun control but is
political outrage really enabling
domestic terrorism
were these acts coordinated
[Music]
or just chaos
among those charged for assault and
damaging government property
is robert gieswein from colorado who
allegedly appears to be affiliated with
the three percenters
the militia group is a splintered
organization that supports the idea
of protecting americans from government
tyranny
mike morris co-founded an offshoot of it
when you see people carrying out
violence wearing the three
percenter insignia how do you feel
so just because somebody wore a three
percent shirt or had a three percent
sticker
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
part of anybody's specific organization
you know it's just like saying you know
how did you feel when the una bomber
bombed somebody when he was wearing
nikes
it truly is made up of members of the
community we have
everybody from walmart employees to
doctors
we have teachers we have lawyers what do
you think of the violence though
that took place i think it's horrible
and i think the people that did that
they should be prosecuted what do you
think it will do to the
patriot and the militia movement what
patriots have seen is if they try and
use their voice
even in a peaceful manner they're
labeled white supremacists they're
labeled
they're labeled home-grown terrorists
they're labeled all these things
whereas when the left did it you didn't
hear that you didn't hear that
condemnation
what does congresswoman lauren beaver
mean to your organization
well i think i think that our
organization
and and her ideals line up
probably pretty closely the insurrection
wasn't solely about the outer edge of
society
the authorities found people right in
the middle
in places like this home to another
individual
now charged with entering the capital
what
strikes you about this area is that
it's unassuming pretty unremarkable
there's a lot of families a lot of
people living close together but in many
respects
it feels like a lot of america
to appreciate the danger in the country
you have to recognize the anger
about freedom and fraud
and in rifle where congresswoman lauren
bobert owns an
open carry restaurant it's easy to find
what do you think of lauren beaubet i
think she's a champion
why good looking little old gal with a
pistol
and gets elected to congress out of this
town
are you kidding me that's like rock star
i love her she's a good friend of mine
not only that she's she's a right winger
she's not a commie
does the idea that she has connections
with
militia concern you
i one of her
assets i think it's a good thing
yes ma'am why because i think
people have to stand up for themselves
next door edward wilkes is one of many
here
who say militia are being unfairly
conflated
with criminals and that the left is
where the danger really lies
there is a saying in our country if
guns commit crime mine are all defective
and if we were as violent as
anti-gunners said we are
there wouldn't be any anti-gunners left
republicans
conservatives gun owners stereotypically
speaking
tend to be more level-headed and calm
because
if we were as violent as rowdy engaging
in acts of
hooliganism and and practical terrorism
we would take over the city but 40
minutes away in
touristy glenwood springs a very
different take
and a mayor who's called for a
congressional investigation
into lauren bovet she tweeted i
am the militia today on the day of the
uh
insurrection she tweeted today is 1776
saying these are my constituents out
there
outside the capitol grounds that's all
incredibly problematic and and what i
would love
for our congresswoman what i would love
for her to do is disavow these
right-wing militia groups
you know they've brought her here they
helped get her elected
they embrace her she embraces them now
she's a u.s congressperson
now she needs to stop despite the
visible
backlash she sparked in some pockets
lauren bobert has condemned the violence
at the capitol
and says she didn't conspire with any
criminals in any way
there is already a new front in the
fallout from that day
online with apps banned and people
thrown off social media
the leader of the proud boys just
designated a terrorist group by canada
told me he's convinced the crackdown
will backfire
and that joe biden must find a way to
hear from others
do you think there'll be more violence i
think that if he doesn't reach
and and listen to these people i think
that yes there will be more violence
you keep silencing people um
you keep uh deep forming them
definancing them
dehumanizing them and they're gonna
react
it's an expected reaction
many argue tougher action is exactly
what's needed
but on january the 6th a broad range of
people
found inspiration in one man one moment
and many grievances
it didn't take long to get them there
and it could take
years to rebuild faith in their own
democracy
understanding their frustrations may be
the best chance america has
of reducing its exposure cordelia lynch
sky news
colorado